[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday october 7th
i'm cindy you the spectator's broadcast
editor
on this week's show
james forsyth and katie boars will join
me to discuss the conservative party
conference in the last episode kate
andrews wondered whether this is when
leveling up will finally be defined well
let's find out
samli the spectator's literary editor
will also be joining the show
now that both conferences are over what
makes a good political speech anyway sam
will be giving us his take
i'll also be speaking to two former
police officers kevin hurley and nusrich
metab is the police in desperate need of
reform or are there just a few bad
apples
and with cop 26 coming up is china
holding its climate corporation as a
bargaining chip for western acquiescence
on other political issues that's what
matt ridley argues in this week's issue
and i'll be discussing with him as well
as the long-time china watcher isabel
hilton and finally is the study of music
being ruined by the culture wars
ian pace head of city university's music
department writes in this week's
magazine about how identity politics has
dominated even classical music
but before we get going if you enjoy
spectator tv you should subscribe to our
youtube channel just click the red
subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the bell icon to make sure
you never miss an episode
and why not subscribe to the spectator
magazine too you can get 10 weeks of the
magazine delivered to your door plus a
bottle of pimps for just 10 pounds to
take up the deal just go to spectator
dot co dot ek forward slash tv offer
hurry though is only while stocks last
first up the conservatives met for party
conference this week despite the ongoing
fuel crisis and labour shortages the
mood in manchester seemed well
distinctly different i'm joined now by
political editor james forsyth and
deputy political editor katie balls to
discuss
james what was the mood in manchester
like
so i think the tories were surprisingly
upbeat when you consider the various
problems that the country is facing at
the moment from yeah supply chain
shortages petrol stations running dry
and the like and i thought it was almost
summed up by boris johnson's speech
which was kind of relentlessly upbeat i
mean the only admission of any kind of
uh problems to come was when he talked
about having an hs waiting list would
get worse before it would get better
but
it was almost what was striking about it
was this is a mid-term conference but
the speech he delivered was almost a
kind of campaign rally speech
rather than an attempt to kind of lay
out the policy prospectus of the
government and i think i think the moon
of a conference was buoyed by fact this
is the first time the kind of tory tribe
has gathered in two years because of
covid and i think that
one of the striking things about the
conference was how little you would have
known about coronavirus if you've been
there there were very few mosques people
were you know there was there wasn't
social distancing and i mean the tory
party took the opportunity to basically
celebrate the 2019 general election
victory and the fact that brexit has now
happened
rather than fretting about the kind of
ideological direction of the party what
the increase in national insurance means
for the size of a state
and all those kind of sort of more
difficult issues i mean the party was
quite happy to be upbeat and boris
johnson was very happy to go along with
that and one of the other striking
things about this conference was it
really was about him you know all the
other cabinet ministers
spoke in the kind of hall but in years
gone past you might have expected a kind
of fringe meeting to take place in was
he got a kind of
jazzy rally style stage
and and spoke for much longer than
anybody else it really was this is now
boris johnson's party well katy critics
have said that you know the conference
itself and certainly boris johnson's
speech has being low on policy and
details and solutions do you think
that's a fair criticism or was it
setting the direction that we should be
expecting from boris johnson at this
moment
i mean it's factually correct in the
sense that there wasn't much policy in
that speech um i think you can say well
the spending review is looming you're
going to have the budget there are
various white papers such as on leveling
up coming up the track and so we are
going to get more announcements soon but
yes this uh conference is more about you
know i'm rallying the base i think
offering some reassurances uh in terms
of concerns about the ideological
direction of the party in boris
johnson's speech you know he invoked
thatcher and talking about that tax rise
so i think there was an effort to say to
those critics on the fringes of the
conference
and yes you know some of the things
we're doing on things that you like or
you wouldn't perhaps think a traditional
tory party would do but think again
because you know i'm still that person
i'm still led by conservative principles
and so i think that was an element of it
in terms of policy as you say very thin
but we did get a sense of some of the
you know developments in this government
such as for example on planning for all
the talk of leveling up
it was quite clear from boris johnson's
speech that when it comes to this
radical planning reform that used to be
talked up by number 10 aids as the plank
of leveling up and it's going to be much
more pivoted to the north and the south
and actually uh when it comes to
what would be known to be nimbies i
think they are going to have a victory
here um with you know fewer developments
in lots of the areas where
there had previously planned to
well james speaking of leveling up last
week you were speaking to kate andrews
about how this could be the moment we
finally find out what it means do you
think conservatives or voters are
clearer now that the conference has
happened what that term means
i think we got a little bit uh more of a
sense about what leveling up means but i
think we still lack kind of metrics by
which to measure whether it has
succeeded or not i thought on on casey's
point about planning i thought it was
very interesting that there was a
conscious effort at this conference to
try and sell leveling up to kind of
southern tories by basically saying
that'll mean less house building in the
south because you know northerners won't
need to come down south to get a job
because the economy in the northwest and
the northeast is going to be doing so
much better
i i think that the challenge on leveling
up you know boris johnson saying in
speech
we're tackling the problems that no
other government's had the guts to
tackle but that's not right um lots of
governments have tried to tackle the
regional productivity gap in the uk they
just haven't succeeded because it is
very difficult and i mean the question
is
whether this government can succeed in
doing this i think we got a little bit
of a sense of what levers they wanted to
pull
but
this is not easy if it was easy it would
have been done before
and casey on that direction um the
conservative party is clearly taking a
new direction under boris johnson was
there discomfort from conservatives to
question you know what are we this high
taxing party is that have they got over
the fact that this is a new direction
that they're going in
well i think it goes back to two things
which is yes there is discomfort there's
discomfort even in cabinet over the tax
rise um you had a free ministers only um
you know raise objections during that
cabinet meeting um but you've also had
you know one of the people who did that
jacob rees-mogg you know say publicly on
a podcast and the uk could not be taxed
any further in terms of the level of
taxation we're currently seeing and you
don't have to walk far to find mps uh
ministers who are deeply uncomfortable
and private over the direction so i do
think we saw a little bit of that in
terms of the tory activists and the base
um i think that you saw richard cena
being grilled on some of these things
when he did his one fringe event with
the um institute of economic affairs um
but it goes back to the same point which
is why are ministers still you know
serving in this government yeah are very
unhappy about the national insurance
rates well there's not really another
alternative and there is a sense that
boris johnson is in a very powerful
position it's what boris johnson wants
to do and that people are just putting
their grumbles aside or in a way keeping
them as grumbles and you know getting on
with it so i don't think you could
describe you know the visitors that in
manchester is happy about the tax rise
but i think it was just not yet at the
point where you know that actually leads
to much because we are in a period of
stable government with that majority of
80.
and james looking forward to the
spending review whereas you know
defenders of the government have said
that's where the policy details are
going to come out what sort of stuff can
we expect can we expect real practical
solutions to what we on the podcast have
talked about on coffee house shops
that's the effing crisis of energy fuel
and food shortages
well there's not that much you can do
about those crises in the spending
review and i think one of the things
that is striking at the end of this
conference season is that by far the
biggest threat to boris johnson is not
kierstarm or some internal rival in the
tory party it is events and i think when
we look back on it we might think that
the fact he didn't use his speech to
prepare people for tough times ahead was
a mistake we might think that he's
definitely left the hostage to fortune
being so dismissive uh about concerns
over inflation you know
if you look at what is happening with
gas prices it is very hard to see how
that doesn't filter through into
significantly higher inflation
add in the labor shortages and and you
can see how inflation could be running
really quite hot you know the banking
which is consistently underestimated how
high inflation will go already thinks
it's going to be four percent by the end
of the year one secretary of state said
to me um this week but they think it
will hit six percent by the end of the
year and that is three times the target
of two percent that the bank is meant to
be working towards and i think that i
think that you know i don't think it's
going to be a kind of kierst armor
attack or kierst armor calling boris
johnson trivial but it's going to cause
boris johnson problems it is going to be
if if voters begin to feel that
livingston that's being squeezed by
rising prices
in those circumstances
you know however good the jokes are it's
going to be much more difficult to get
people to laugh along
and katie let's finish up on kia stammer
as well because obviously both party
conferences are over now
we've painted quite a happy picture of
the mood and conservative party at the
moment despite everything that's going
on is labour worried about that
well they have been behind the tories in
the polls for so long now i don't think
there's a fresh fear i think that the
conference season hasn't particularly
changed much in terms of you know
voting intention but i still think
kirsten ends labour conference with a
few wins and i think we could start to
see that in the leadership in the sense
they did manage to change some of the
rules that means that kierstama you know
doesn't worry so much about a threat
from the left
and also it's harder to deselect mps
which means mps might feel more
emboldened to take stances um so i think
that there is something for them to work
with there but yes i think it's exposed
really how far apart the two sides are
and the fact as james touches on that
four things to really change i don't
think it's down to kill start upping the
ante he gave a decent leader speech and
it pulled pretty well when people ask
you about specific speech but it hasn't
transferred until oh well now i'm gonna
vote for labor and so i think it's
really about events outside of
kierstama's control and when they happen
whether he can take advantage of them
james and katie thanks for joining
spectator tv
now boris johnson brought the conference
to a close with a speech full of
flourish and bombast
and we knew
that some people would still be anxious
so we sent top government
representatives to our sweatiest
to show that anyone could dance
perfectly safely
and wasn't he brilliant my friend
let's hear it
let's hear it for john von goby
living proof
living proof
living proof that we
we you all represent the most
jiving hip happening and generally funka
potterson party in the world
but critics say the 45 minutes were
light on substance so was it a success
i'm joined now by sam leath the
spectator's literary editor who has
watched both boris johnson's and
kiyosama's respective speeches
sam what did you make of boris's speech
was it successful
well i thought it was as i wrote a
colossal success
i say that with some regret because um
i'm i'm one of that team of sort of
storm right types he'd actually quite
like to see him fall on his face and
you know you expect
in the circumstances of the outside
world boris to come out
you know looking a bit cowed a bit
defensive a bit shame-faced you know
because the world does seem very much to
be crumbling around his ears
and yet he's never been more tiggerish
and i think
you know a lot of the complaints about
that speech which basically said
you know it it ignored what was really
going on in the world it was light on
policy it was you know
mendacious and as much as he framed our
withdrawal from afghanistan as a triumph
rather than a catastrophe
um you know all those complaints sort of
missed the point
what he was trying to do with that
speech and did i thought with
extraordinary success was just present
himself uh it was mood music it was pure
pathos um technically speaking you know
in rhetorical terms it's all about
look
be cheerful be happy everything's going
great i mean of course
in a sense it was delusional because it
was within that hall and he ignored
anything that didn't fit that narrative
but
the overall effect was a vibe and that
vibe was
this is fantastic it's all going great
um and
isn't it brilliant to be in our gang
and i think that was what conference
obviously desperately wanted i mean he
got a huge standing ovation and i think
it probably will reach beyond the
faithful a bit because you see those
clips exerted and you know he's being
sometimes grown worthily but
nevertheless he's being funny
he's being
light-hearted which which projects
confidence
you know people go oh it's trivial it's
it's ignoring every you know these grave
matters but it also
you know having the hood spa to ignore
the gravity of the situation and to be
cheerful
suggests you know just plants in the
mind
you know does he know something we don't
i mean it's also just entertaining to
watch as well isn't it i mean and like
maybe kierstama's things to read or
things to hear
yes i mean actually i'm funny enough
though um i'm reading the life of the
young h.g wells at the moment and
there's an exchange where wells and
churchill boris is great um
great
you know hero
um wells sends churchill some of his
books and they're quite friendly and
churchill says at one point
um i've eaten all the suet you give me
but i do need some jam
um because wells of course you know he
was banging on about his socialist ideas
but he was also telling romances and
fairy stories and exciting science
fictional
adventures
and
you know kierstarma is try though he
might very much more suit than jam and
boris is jammed with almost no suet at
all certainly in that speech
what what do you think voters like more
than because there's a really
interesting opinion poll out in the
aftermath of the borough speech where
people said that kieslama came across
more competent but they might say that
and we also thought theresa may was more
competent but at the ballot box do
people really care about competency as
opposed to you know the showmanship well
i'd like to think people do care about
competence i mean i was quite surprised
and and in a way heartened that that
poll came out almost immediately after i
wrote a thing saying that boris's speech
was a colossal triumph
paul came up saying saying the general
public you're out of touch sam which
made me think yeah maybe i got that
wrong and perhaps you know the public
does want more substance if you like
i think overall though
it is not to be underestimated in
politics which is why boris has got as
far as he has given that he's done a 100
different things that would have
entirely sunk
you know any other politician
is this thing aristotle called ethos you
know how you present yourself how people
read your character and the sense they
get of you and if they think that you're
fun and likable you will go quite a long
way i mean of course
competent dependable and trustworthy are
also qualities that a good ethos appeal
will project and that boris often
struggles with um
but it is you know not to be
underestimated the extent to which how
people feel about you as a person seems
to govern their responses um i'm not a
psychologist or a political scientist so
as i say i was
you know surprised and pleasantly so in
a way that
um
you know the electorate
does have a limited tolerance um
for
you know a speech that doesn't address
any of the
you know major issues but
you know
so it goes
yeah well you in your analysis of
boris's speech you talk about his use of
humor and how you know
light and subtle it is but at the same
time do you think that this jamminess
that you've talked about
risks being too different to what people
are feeling on the ground so that it
makes him look out of touch well i think
that's true there is the danger that you
know if you are all you know cry i mean
the classic instance is the crisis what
crisis you know
um
if you look like you're completely out
of touch
that's a problem
i mean i think in this this case he was
yeah it was a specific
arena and a specific kind of moment
where what he was trying to do was put a
bit of
you know
a tiger back into the party's tank to
reassure wobblers i mean
you know barack obama
knows obviously every day in a very
different way but on the election trail
in 2008 there's a lovely description i
think it's in david remnick's biography
where he says
you know there'd be some terrible gaffe
or attack line from the republicans
and
everybody would be running around with
their hair on fire can play you know ah
we're doomed we're doomed and obama
would just go chill the f out we got
this
and that's you know boris in his kind of
capering way was doing a version of the
chili f out we got this thing he was
trying to
trying to put a radically different mood
music on um
but of course yeah you do
you can't take your audience too far you
know there's a sort of piece of elastic
i mean any
rhetorical moment any speech
you're trying to move the audience from
one place or one mood or one position to
another one
but
it's you know you're tugging them with a
bit of elastic so you can
only go so far before the elastic breaks
and that's why when people plan speeches
they go right okay
where do we think the audience are now
where do we think we can get them to
sam thanks for joining us
next since sarah everard's killer has
been sentenced another officer from his
unit has been charged with rape and has
surfaced that 26 met officers have
committed sex crimes since 2016.
is there a culture of misogyny in the
force and does the police need desperate
reform
i'm joined now by nazareth mettab former
superintendent with the met police and
kevin hurley former police and crime
commissioner with the surrey police
nursery let's start with you pretty
patel has announced this public inquiry
into what went wrong with a mets
stealing of the investigation of sarah
everard's death what do you think
they're going to find or what should
they find well firstly i actually
welcome the fact that the home secretary
has finally ordered a public inquiry
which would be better than
the commissioner carrying out her own
review marking her own homework
really quite honestly nothing short of a
public inquiry will do because girls and
women
women and girls deserve better not only
from policing but from the government
what they will find well um
institutional denial
uh toxic culture poor leadership i think
uh all the way from sergeant to
the commissioner and so i hope
that the recommendations of this public
query inquiry are implemented and we're
yet to find out the remit the scope and
the objectives tie even the timeline and
actually who will head this but i
absolutely am delighted that we do we
are going to have a public inquiry
you were a police officer what did you
see in the force that makes you think
that this sort of misogyny is
institutional
well sexism and um misogyny have never
gone away
they've just been eroded they've come
it's come under a different
label
and you know
it's live and kicking in 2021.
now it just manifests itself in a
different form it unconsciously
influences policing uh performance it
can be detected
in operational decisions on the ground
in selection in process
and the way the victims are treated
where the female victims are treated of
domestic abuse sexual abuse so it's
everywhere it's never gone away kevin
would you agree with that from your time
in the force
um
there's some aspects i'd go along with
but i think what i would
lead off by saying in answer to your
original question
in some ways i think a public inquiry is
a bad idea because it will further
shatter the already badly damaged morale
of the police service that we all
reliable but i actually think it's a
good idea and the reason why i will say
that is this
there are two things that leap out at me
from the sarah everlard
murder from that monster wayne cousins
a a predator sexual offender who just
happened to be a police officer he could
have been anything else but he would
still have probably done that
and that is
had the two incidents
of indecent exposure being investigated
properly in the first case by kent
years ago and more promptly by the met
three days before that he would have
been arrested
and he would have been
probably stopped they were both very
easy to solve and the reason why i say
they should have been done is this in
days gone by
when i was a junior detective we knew
full well that a flasher was a precursor
towards becoming a serial offender
so a proper skilled
trained detective who understood that
would have investigated that as a matter
of urgency
and such was the hunger in those days of
young ambitious detectives to make a
mark
a crime where there was a registration
number and you could identify the
suspect they would have fallen on that
because to use the police terms that
would have been an easy body to get and
show i'm a good investigator
so
kevin is saying that it's not a problem
of a misogynistic culture but a problem
of cuts what do you think about that
well kevin comes up with some really
excellent points and you know i concur
with some of them
but
the fact is that it's the culture you
know this wasn't an isolated incident
unfortunately this wasn't an isolated
incident and two days um or this weekend
we saw another colleague of wayne
cullens from the uh protection
parliamentary diplomatic protection
command being charged with rape
since 2016 27 officers have committed
sexual offenses including rape
sexual assault voyeurism and possessing
images of children 800 allegations of
domestic
abuse and 52 of all officers that get
charged with sexual misconduct do not
lose their job so it's a culture and
absolutely not every police officer is
an abuser as as uh kevin has said the
detectives that carried out this inquiry
were excellent that their work was
absolutely brilliant but as i said not
all police officers are abusers what it
is is the environment that enables and
enhances them to flourish people like um
wayne cousins so it's the minority
of abusers that are protected by the
majority in terms of that culture why is
there no punishment there when people
make mistakes like that and you know
it's from something that you didn't
mention but the nicknames that are given
to these you know bad apples and people
knew that wayne cousins was you know a
creepy guy to say that at least that
they nicknamed him the rapist why why is
there this culture of protection and no
punishment
it's it's more of a
as i've kind of touched on it you know
he his nickname was the rapist in fact
he took a prostitute with him to um
a colleague's anniversary and allegedly
a prostitute turned up at his work to
get some money and he told his
colleagues that she was a prostitute now
why didn't anybody pick up on that why
didn't his supervisors pick up on that
and get alerted and do something about
it it comes back to the same thing and
that's the culture which enables and
endorses people supports them and they
then flourish in that culture because
people are afraid
to actually do something about it and
also there's a culture of denial and you
know turning a blind eye which is
becomes an ethos of the organization so
the people like wayne cousins are able
to flourish and are able to get away
with things like that in terms of
punishment i think you know sanctions uh
kevin's touched up on the cuts that have
gone um you know that have taken place
so you don't have enough skilled people
to do the job that they should be doing
kevin let me bring you back in here i
mean isn't that the answer to your
question earlier of why uh those
indecent exposure incidents didn't lead
you anywhere because of this culture
no my let me before i answer let me tell
you this
what there have not been any similar
instances to wayne cousins in the 42
years i've been associated with policing
this was a rape abduction and brutal
murder i am not aware of a single police
officer who has ever been convicted of
that offence
now back on to why do people not get
dealt with
if there is evidence and they appear
before a criminal court they'll be
convicted and fired
or if there is evidence they appear
before a discipline board which is
chaired
by an independent
non-police legally qualified person
if the evidence is there they will also
be fired so that's completely
independent there but going back
to the two points about the indecent
exposures
i sense you
indecent exposures are not given
the amount of investigative effort that
they should do
in the way many many other offences
that are clashed as low level it's got
nothing to do
with misogyny or culture it's got to do
with what government targets were
established that the police were counted
on
so they were counted on if you sold
burglary but indecent exposure was not
one this tended to drive a culture
therefore of driving investigative
effort in the directions of whatever
government measured yeah can i just come
in there kevin um kevin's kind of made
some really good points and important
points about the culture that i'd like
to pick up one of the things that kevin
said was that you know um
officers haven't been uh convicted of
the same crime as wayne cousins he's
absolutely right because it's the first
murder we've had in the uh serving
police officer in the history of the
metropolitan police service but 26
are met police officers in the last five
years have been convicted of sexual
offenses which includes rape
so it's there and in terms of the
culture of uh allegedly taking uh
prostitute to a wed uh anniversary and
also take a prostitute turning up to his
workplace to claim money it was wayne
cousins who actually uh wayne yeah was
wayne cousins actually told his
colleagues that that was a prostitute
and she came for money so
that wasn't picked up and that's my
concern and it comes back to these
specialist units which are uh very silo
and very misogynistic because some of
those officers you have to look at their
tenure they have been in those units for
decades and they become resistant to
change and they removed from a lot of
operational policing so
in terms of the culture i come back to
the same thing over and over again it's
a culture of denial it's a culture of
turning a blind eye and
enabling and endorsing people to be able
to flourish to keep that behavior going
and racism sexism misogyny
is perpetuated because poor leadership
leadership doesn't tackle it and we've
covered that but also it's allowed to
fester prevail and it becomes an ethos
of the organization and i think that's
what's happened in policing as a whole
and we have to be able to firstly admit
the problem and then be able to deal
with it and that's where we are
kevin nusrat thanks for joining
spectator tv
now in the run-up to cop26 how much
involvement can we expect china to have
in the global effort to tackle climate
change
matt ridley spectator contributor and
author of how innovation works argues
that china is using climate cooperation
as a bargaining chip for western silence
on inconvenient topics like human rights
abuse and territorial encroachment
he joins spectator tv now together with
journalist isabel hilton founder of
china dialogue which scrutinizes china's
environmental record so matt just start
with why do you think that china is
using climate change as a bargaining
chip
well i think uh china has made it fairly
explicit in recent days and weeks
particularly a comment from the foreign
minister where he said that climate
change cannot be
separated from the larger people's
republic of china u.s relations
environment
um and
this has become clear in in other
statements too there's a very aggressive
editorial in uh one of the communist
party newspapers about how
um actually they quite like britain at
the moment but america really has to
moderate its behavior if it wants a
climate
agreement if it wants cooperation on the
climate issue and it just looks to me as
if increasingly china thinks about this
issue in terms of what it can extract in
the way of
better behavior towards china
than
the issue itself
israel would you agree with that
um well not really i mean the global
times is notorious for aggressive
statements about almost everyone and you
know next week it might be you know the
uk is is horrible and and the united
states is is our our close friend
this changes um depending on the agenda
of the global times
um or it's editor who xi jin
as for wangi the foreign minister well
fortunately wangi doesn't do climate
negotiations for china and in fact the
foreign minister in china is not very
high up the pecking order so
again the foreign ministry is intent on
displaying warfare diplomacy and and
being very assertive in its uh
statements about foreign policy but the
real action is going on elsewhere so the
action is going on uh partly through the
working out of the fourteen five-year
plan partly through the state council
and largely through xi jinhua who is the
chief climate negotiator who talks
directly
with john kerry and they've met
nearly 20 times already so there clearly
is a lot of action going on
which is shielded the only talk about
climate uh in that negotiation and
that's the one that counts
well matt let me bring you in on this
one because i know from your writings
and your book that you believe in
economic growth and that you believe
with greater economic growth some of
these environmental problems can then be
tackled you know using technology to
tackle climate change rather than you
know maybe obscene epistemianess or hair
shirts and that sort of stuff if china
is still behind america in terms of per
capita pollution isn't that because
china is still behind america in terms
of capital gdp i.e the chinese people
are still transitioning to a much more
middle class developed
living standards so should they be given
a slightly different understanding on
their pollution in the same way that for
example the west went through the
industrial revolution
well what happens when a country
industrializes is that at first it uses
more energy
and then gradually becomes more
efficient isabel made this point earlier
and we've seen
enormous improvements in the west in the
amount of emissions you need to produce
a dollar of gdp or a pound of gdp
and that's because of innovation it's
because of new technologies that enable
us to use fossil fuels more efficiently
to switch to lower carbon fossil fuels
like natural gas rather than
coal
and to
use other technologies like nuclear i'm
not at all convinced that renewables are
in any way relevant to that transition
because an awful lot of fossil fuels is
used in producing them they're very low
energy efficiency in terms of energy
return on energy invested extremely
unreliable so you have to have backups
to them if we want to solve this problem
if we want to have
a a functioning modern industrial
wealthy society
without producing any carbon emissions
then we're either going to have to
tackle
burying carbon in the ground through a
carbon capture and storage industry or
we're going to have to get very serious
about nuclear fission and fusion in the
longer term i personally think it's the
the most of the rest uh is simply a
waste of time and playing into the hands
of those who who you know really don't
care about the environment they just
care about making money and you know
frankly filling the north sea with with
industrial structures um while
doing an enormous amount of very dirty
mining in china for the materials
doesn't feel to me like an
environmentally beneficial thing to be
doing well but do you think that china's
coal fueled economic growth is something
that is you know
understandable
or rather justifiable
well
clearly coal is an extremely efficient
form uh source of energy
there's no question about that we i come
from the northeast of england uh where
coal mining is is you know built the the
prosperity of this country there's no
question about that um uh but
uh the
the
degree to which china is prepared to
expand that industry and use it in
pretty inefficient ways
doesn't seem to me something we should
simply ignore and excuse
i don't think anyone is ignoring or
excusing china's call use to be fair
there are questions
around energy security which are being
exacerbated by jewish strategic tensions
which may explain part of china's um
continuing uh expansion of its domestic
coal
but you know china has promised to peak
its emissions and that will involve
closing down a great deal of its coal
capacity it's promised to peak its
emissions by 2030 or before actually and
certainly its net zero target is 2016
not 2060 or after as as matt said there
are other ways that countries change
their energy profile um beyond
innovation um and
one of them is by changing their
industrial base and china has gone
through that
very heavily emitting you know
construction of infrastructure all that
heavy industrial development which uh
countries tend to go through in the in
the rapid sort of catch-up phase and
then they transition to higher value
technologies they stop doing so much you
know heavy dirty stuff they they built
all their infrastructure so their
emissions tend to level off uh because
they're engaged in economic activities
that demand less primary energy input
the other thing that we did of course
was we outsourced our emissions in a
very large uh degree to to china by
outsourcing manufacturing to a low-wage
economy
in china and and
almost all western countries did this
which impacted their own emissions
profile but of course did
make china's go the other way so there
are
this is an endless complicated argument
if you want to go the route of
you know
telling a simple story about emissions
it it doesn't really work and as i said
i think the best way to tackle this
problem is for each country to
to try it's uh to try its best to put
its own house in order and china you
know for all the frustrations that we
all have uh with china's emissions and
particularly its coal sector
it's a great deal better than it was 10
years ago and as long as it goes on
moving in the right direction i think we
should encourage it to move faster
rather than criticize it for everything
it does matt would you like to come back
on that
well i i just don't think this
conversation is happening in a vacuum
the the the point is this is happening
at a time when there are huge human
rights problems in china a terrible
suppression of liberty uh appalling
things happenings to the uyghur peoples
the crushing of hong kong
and a terrible pandemic that originated
in china and the investigation into the
origin of which we are simply not being
given a transparent opportunity to
pursue
and it feels as if
quite a lot of politicians in the west
are pulling their punches on some of
those issues
because they want chinese cooperation on
climate and that seems to me it should
be brought to the attention of the
public i i'm not sure that there's any
evidence for that often politicians pull
their punches on china i agree and i i
don't dissent from
anything that mata said about the human
rights abuses and so on um but they tend
to pull their punches for uh for
economic reasons because they hope to do
business and you know uh we we saw that
particularly with the cameron government
which um i think that was fairly closely
acquainted with um which you know
adopted a policy of complete appeasement
in a basement to china and was lavishly
praised amongst others by the global
times for doing so and and essentially
told yes that's how we want foreigners
to behave um i don't think it did
anybody very much good to be honest but
what i find
most puzzling about this argument is i'm
not quite sure how not cooperating on
china improves human right and not
cooperating on climate improves human
rights in china or indeed improves any
of the other ills that we wish to
address
it it makes no difference
well i think it it's it it's more a
question of whether or not
in our pursuit of climate we are letting
that get a climate agreements we are
letting that get in the way of other
interests and and i think that does
happen and i think you know the the
degree to which
uh the the conference of the parties in
glasgow
um has
partly because it's been delayed for a
year um
intruded on almost every uh diplomatic
conversation over the last year year or
two
is problematic we know that the glasgow
conference is not going to achieve very
much we know that because it's the 26th
uh such meeting and the previous 25
haven't solved the problem and they've
come up with some extraordinary slights
of hands to sort of pretend they're
solving the problem i mean the paris
agreement basically came up with a non
it insisted it was going to come up with
a binding treaty in fact it came up with
a binding treaty to have non-binding
promises which is a sort of slight of
hand
and the you know the cancun agreement
came up with
a an agreement to create but not to fund
a fund of climate
we're going to have some similar sort of
compromise out of glasgow is it really
worth it uh to have these tens of
thousands of people uh dissent
descending upon britain to have this
rather meaningless conversation and at
the same time i do think we pull our
punches on china because of it
and yes i do think that we we need to be
calling much more openly
for example for proper investigation
into the origin of the virus when
australia did that they simply had trade
sections slapped on them that just
doesn't feel like a very sensible way
for a a global power to behave
well i i'm i'm very happy to criticize
china for for for that i just don't
think it's related to the question of
climate australia um wasn't complaining
about china's climate policy and
australia actually is pretty much a
laggard in climate negotiations it's one
of the countries with a very very high
per capita emissions so i i'm not quite
sure the relevance of of of that episode
to cop 26 and the idea that the
conferences and the whole unf uh triple
c process hasn't achieved anything is
frankly
extremely questionable i mean look at
the counter factual where would we be
without it our emissions would be much
higher we would not be innovating we
would not be attempting an energy
transition without this whole process
it's a very long and complicated
business to upend uh the world's uh
energy sources and the great many people
of course have vested interests in the
existing uh energy sources and and the
traditional high emitting carbon sectors
and they obfuscate and they resist and
they cause a great deal of difficulty um
to those who are trying to find a way
through but that doesn't mean that no
progress is made i mean we have made
enormous progress both in our scientific
understanding of the human impacts on
climate and in the many ways that we can
tackle it and
many countries have reduced their carbon
footprint dramatically the european
union has a really remarkable uh project
the eur the the european green deal
uh countries are coming up with
transition plans as a result of the
paris agreement none of that would have
happened without you
the the major reduction in
the
emissions intensity in the united states
was due to the discovery of shale gas
and the cheap gas replacing coal as a
source of fuel that's the big impact
that's come on emissions in in there and
the per capita emissions of the united
states are still twice as high as china
so it's not really an example you said
that the the emissions reduction had
come as a result of the treaties i don't
think that's the case the emissions
reduction has come as a result of
changes in technology within the fossil
fuel industry and other reductions have
come as a result of policies adopted
because of the unf triple c process and
the discussions around climate change
and the reiteration of the scientific
evidence of of anthropogenic climate
change all of this has been contested at
every point um but nevertheless it has
managed to advance and i find it
really quite surprising
that you should argue that it would have
happened regardless given the degree of
resistance that there has been by uh you
know any number of sectors and and
interests that that wish not to see us
change
well let's let's continue talking about
climate change and tackling climate
change and cop26 closer to cop26 but
we're running out of time so matt i just
want to finish on one final question to
you which is that you mentioned all of
these human rights abuses that are
happening in china all of the ways it's
behaving in ways that the west doesn't
like
going forward what do you think is the
west's relationship with china on
climate change what do you think that
should be
if these other things don't change so
what i guess what i'm asking is is
cooperation justifiable should it happen
if china doesn't stop oppressing the
uyghur people if china doesn't stop
oppressing the hong kong people you know
if china doesn't stop doing these other
things
should we just not cooperate with china
on climate change
no i think of course we have to
cooperate and on climate change and on
everything else we you know we we live
in the same planet and we have to try
and find a way of of living with people
but i think that the process of these
vast meetings and the lead up to them
and the the desire to extract
concessions has led us to
um
sometimes be somewhat uh inadequate in
the way we talk about other issues
and
i therefore think that it'd be much
better to get away from these vast
annual meetings with uh
i'm sorry to say futile outputs because
they are futile uh seen from outside by
ordinary people
these are talking shops that produce
pieces of paper these aren't where the
action happens and you know the the
improvements have come from technology
not from policy 90 of them i would say
well matt perhaps president xi agrees
with you and that's why he's not turning
up to cop 26 in november thanks for
joining spectator tv both
and finally is the study of music being
ruined by the culture wars ian pace
pianism musicologist and head of music
at city university in london writes this
week that efforts to decolonize the
curriculum have gone too far
ian joins me now
ian there's a debate raging in the
classical music world at the moment what
is it
well there have been a number of recent
events which have taken musicology away
from just on campuses and has actually
been have actually been reported in the
wider media
um one of these most recently is the
high profile resignation
of a professor at royal holloway
university of london jp harper scott
on the grounds that he felt that his
profession was becoming overly dogmatic
and he felt certain sort of political
arguments were almost blackmailing
scholars in a sense
there was also been a very high profile
controversy relating to what would seem
very esoteric to some
the analytical work of the austrian
music theorist heinrich schenker
who also
made a range of statements and
publications which involves you know
what by any accounts are quite extreme
racist sentiments and this has led to a
whole controversy about whether we
should
teach schenker or not whether he is
acceptable
whether his political views his racial
views are somehow mirrored in his
analytical work
and there have been other things
particularly in the united states
where some have been arguing against
what would be seen as tried and tested
and long-established scholarly methods
for ascertaining truth and veracity
making sure one is scrupulous with
sources
users
uses strong arguments avoids logical
fallacies does one's homework
with some saying that instead
scholarships should be judged on its
ability to do good its ability to sort
of contribute to social justice
everything like this which i would say
is a heavy heavy politicization of
scholarship and is very dangerous in its
own way
but these
i would say are not wholly new phenomena
they've just uh
increased in volume as it were in recent
years but they go back uh several
decades to certain
certain movements which uh began around
then or at least uh began in a certain
direction around there which i think
have led to the current situation that
is true in some parts of academia
well certainly the debate over art and
artists and i remember you know wagner
obviously had some unsavory views to say
the least but you know people enjoy his
music do you think that
is now coming to um a point at which
people are now thinking more about the
the person and their views rather than
the music that they create
that the balance has shifted in that way
yes in many ways and oddly that's
i would say in some sense as a reversion
to a 19th century approach where there
was such a fixation on biography on
mythologies around artists and the link
between the biography and the work was
seen to be straightforward i don't think
it is straightforward
what the
there are people who were
you know
really quite despicable people who were
very fine artists and there were really
nice
ones uh with with very with with very
sort of equitable views who were very
mediocre at the same time now there has
been a whole range of scholarship
looking critically at the relationship
between biography and work for all types
of artists this is much more advanced in
the field of literary biography than it
is in musical biography overall but i
think most of the
rigorous scholars uh would be wary of uh
positing that you can just simply draw a
line from one thing to another an
example of this uh arnold schoenberg in
the year 1908
for a period his wife left him for
someone else an artist and that's the
same year that his music shifted
towards an atonal music language and
music which lacks the
gravitation around a singular pitch
which underpins most
uh music in the western art tradition
one of the most radical directions has
ever happened in
music now it's very easy to sort of
write this off as
just a response to a particular event in
his life but i don't think it's anything
like so simple as that
not least his wife returned to him in
time and but he still pursued this past
for most of the rest of his
compositional career
but to respond more directly to your
question i think actually in some ways
writing potted biography or writing
writing sort of
very informal
inferences from about life and work is
much easier than grappling with the very
details and the own internal logics of
music and
i think there are tendencies within
musicology and in music education to
to avoid having to put the work in that
the latter requires
because by doing the latter then you can
look at how to what to what extent what
you can discern about the actual work
does uh relate to the biography and
that's a critical question and something
to be re-asked in every single case in
my view and ian it's not just the
political views that we're talking about
isn't it it's also the identities of the
composers you know we might be able to
make quite a fair critique that in the
west we study a lot about white male
composers and not much about people from
rest of the world or other ethnicities
and other financial backgrounds perhaps
do you think there's something in that
that we need to diversify and consider
social backgrounds when we're learning
about music as well
well i certainly think we should be
thinking about social backgrounds and
the social media in which music operated
at all times so how that relates to the
actual music again i think is a complex
critical question
there's no doubt that the whole history
of western classical music is dominated
by white men
i mean one can argue that uh for
before the 20th century uh the number of
people who would now be classified
outside of caucasian groups was
relatively small so it's not surprising
that you would see a white domination
but the male domination is a wholly
different matter again that reflects
many other aspects of history and that's
probably true of many other musical
traditions in the world
there are extraordinarily important
musical traditions coming from china
coming from india coming from indonesia
from various places in the arab world
from various parts of africa and the
last thing i would ever want to suggest
is that these are any less
worthy of study and attention than those
in the west and then also sort of folk
and vernacular and popular traditions in
the west also
definitely repay very serious study as
well so i'm not trying to argue for the
supremacy of the western classical
tradition
but i do worry about a situation in
which that one tradition comes under
particular sort of sensor
compared to others and
whether
somehow there's guilt to be associated
with having a gravitation towards that
which i think would be seen as very
unacceptable if similar arguments were
applied to other traditions
yes absolutely i mean you would be a
perversion of the diversity agenda
really um but ian let me ask you on on
what you said just now which is that
whether or not the identity of a
composer differs changes uh contributes
to the music that they made do you think
you know different gender identities or
different ethnic identities composers of
those backgrounds compose different
types of music can we talk about you
know female music or male music is is
there anything worthy to be said about
that
i think those terms and those concepts
are very problematic
if i took the example
um with the growth of queer musicology
in the end of the 1980s onwards
there were a lot of people quite
invested in the idea that there was a
gay music and a straight music and
debates raged about was handel gay as
composed of straight bach or schubert
compared to beethoven or gravel compared
to dbc
i sort of feel that if
someone had some information that it was
the other way around in any of those
cases they'd probably be able to find
some way of arguing that this is
reflected in the music
i'm not ruling out there could be some
sort of essential identity to
what gay composers write so much as you
never find unity amongst an
extraordinary diverse range
of figures uh but i don't think we're in
any position to be able to assert it yet
um and
well the scholar charles rosen once said
uh you might be able to observe general
tendencies but in the cases he was
talking about schubert it's the
individual case that matters
um
and how schubert's
music reflected what he may have been
same-sex attracted
at a time in history when perhaps the
concept of being gay did not really
exist in the way that it does today what
that means in terms of his music is a
very very complex
area to
deal with and i worry that there's a lot
of easy platitudes made about this
there's one musicologist who has argued
the harmony in schubert's music follows
different patterns to those in
beethoven's
less
less suffused with what we call dominant
harmonies which doesn't mean what you
would usually mean by dominant but it
simply means for those who are musicians
it means a chord based on the fifth
degree of the scale
um which is a cornerstone of beethoven's
music and many others but schubert takes
a somewhat different approach
and this musical just also observed a
similar tendency in tchaikovsky who no
one doubts the sexuality of him
but then
someone else responded that you can also
find in between those two figures the
same
types of harmonic progressions in the
work of france list who was about as
straight as you would get and it's quite
a womanizer so
linking this to sexuality is you may be
able to find some cases to spot that
argument but they're often
counterexamples as well and those
equally need to be taken on board
ian pace thank you for joining spectator
tv
and that's it for this week if you
enjoyed this episode don't forget to
subscribe to the spectators youtube
channel just click the subscribe button
at the bottom of this video and the bell
icon to make sure you never miss another
episode
thanks for watching and do join us again
next week
[Music]
you